let's hear from some more people via
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to Kansas where Casey
from Kansas Casey because you're in
Kansas obviously you're really happy
that the Kansas City Kansas Chief won
the Super Bowl right
watch any sports balls oh okay it was a
joke because Trump once seemed to think
that the Kansas City Chiefs were from
Kansas rather than Missouri but it went
over like a lead balloon my friend I'm
sorry I'm just as ignorant as him on
that fair but no but hold on Casey you
know that Kansas City Missouri is in a
different state yeah you do okay good
all right
okay but uh I just had a question
because somebody was talking you were
talking about like the how defensive and
slow the Democrats are sometimes yes sir
do you think that the Democrats should
just like
stop Focus testing and fixating on polls
entirely like I don't know that
Democrats are do what are you in what
evidence do you have that Democrats are
focusing on polls
like in the first six months of Biden's
presidency he was not really doing much
okay
that's right Focus test vaccine rollout
they came up with the phrase mega mega
yeah they didn't accomplish anything
like he came out and he said oh these
are like mega mega Republicans it turned
out that that was from democratic
advisors doing like Focus testing with a
bunch of you know groups being like okay
yeah this sounds the worst mega mega or
something you know what's crazy is this
is the first I've ever heard that term
uh I think it was mega mega but it might
have been something else no you're right
I just Googled it it's absolutely true
that that was a thing but you mentioning
it is the first I've ever heard of it
but yeah back when this was happening I
was just like it felt like the Democrats
weren't really like doing like an
aggressive strategy for a while then the
first thing that Biden comes up with is
Mega Maga after sitting on a focus group
for six months nothing
that sort of stuff is a problem at all
yeah I mean I think it's kind of I think
it's just kind of a waste you know um
and and here's the thing it's not wrong
to think that the right nicknames for
things can be effective because let's be
honest
Trump got the term crooked Hillary to
stick to Hillary Clinton Trump got a
sleepy Joe Biden to stick to Joe Biden
among certainly so like he didn't take
six months to come up with that well we
don't know we I guess I'm not sure how
long it took him but he came up with it
is the point so I think it's right to
think that messaging and nicknames and
those types of things can can be
important I just don't necessarily know
that focus group testing them is the
right way to go
okay yeah and do you do you think that
they should get new strategy advisors
like entirely well I don't know I mean
maybe yeah it's very easy for me to say
that I think the approach needs to
change it's possible that the current
advisors and strategists would be fine
if they could agree on what is the
different approach going to be I don't
know they want to do that though yeah I
guess no
but yeah that's all I had all right well
Casey thank you for the call I
appreciate it okay thank you there is
Casey from Kansas not Missouri from
Kansas